In 2007,
Dr. Mackill and the International Rice
Research Institute led a field
experiment with a strain of rice, IR64,
that contained the Sub1 gene. On day 25,
the fields flooded for around 17 days.
As the water began to clear, we see
that many of the regular IR64 plants
have died, and those that survived have
severely stunted growth. In contrast,
all of the IR64 plants containing Sub1
survived the flood. The whole plot is
full of healthy rice plants, while the
regular IR64 side has only sparse
patches of growth. The final harvested
rice piles show us a wonderful result.
The yield of IR64+Sub1
rice is double that of plain IR64.
Sub1 has saved the day.
With that successful test, Sub1
varieties of rice exploded in
popularity throughout Asia. Farmers
across the region began adopting these
submergence tolerant rice strains, and
as floods came through, their rice
continued to thrive. In addition, they
claimed, the Sub1 rice tasted just as
good as their traditional rice strains,
further boosting their adoption by
other farmers. Let's listen to the
story of Maha Jha, an actual farmer in
East India who planted Sub1 rice.
Currently, there are over 5 million
farmers in Asia growing Sub1 varieties
of rice, which has brought food
security to over 70 million people
across the continent.